pasa otro día sin agua potable para
tener residente de Jackson y madre de
seis hijos en esta ciudad de mayoría
afro en el estado de Mississippi una
planta de tratamiento del agua falló
dejando a los locales frustrados y
buscando desesperadamente soluciones
no quiero agua marrón no quiero Agua
Verde no podemos cepillarnos los dientes
o bañarnos pero no puedo no bañar a mis
hijos entonces tengo que usar este cloro
y me arriesgo a blanquear a mis hijos
yo como madre haré lo que sea necesario
para sobrevivir en esta crisis de agua
en algunos edificios como este para
personas mayores no hubo agua durante
dos días el servicio regreso el
miércoles pero aún no es seguro para su
uso este jueves la administración del
presidente biden Se comprometió a dar
respuesta al problema
la administración Se comprometió a
ayudar a la gente de Mississippi a hacer
frente a esta emergencia actual y vamos
a seguir trabajando con los funciona del
gobierno Estatal y local para explorar
todas las opciones
el estado de Mississippi instaló siete
sitios de distribución de agua para
ayudar a abastecer a los ciudadanos pero
para muchos el problema de salubridad no
es nuevo
esto ha sido un problema para mí desde
que vine en 1991 siempre me dijeron que
no bebiera esa agua
la política racista extrema se está
poniendo ante la gente
ya no podemos darnos el lujo de seguir
jugando juegos con las vidas de 175 mil
residentes aquí en Jackson
el alcalde de Jackson atribuyó la avería
de la planta de agua a la reciente
inundación del río pero el gobernador
republicano Tetris culpa años de
mantenimiento deficiente hasta el punto
de que ya no podía producir agua
corriente